you hear people say well copernicus
realized that the earth revolves around
the sun isn't one of the points of
general relativity to say that you can
actually view it both ways you can just
change the coordinates according to
system technically
okay yeah you're right yes you're right
you're right in fact
um
in fact
if you ask don't put this way because i
think it's interesting
if you ask the
the question um
is is the earth going around the sun or
the sun going around the earth
uh
let me put a simple question is the
earth the center of the universe
is that a scientific question yes of
course it's a scientific question right
in fact jumping out from this
idea that the center center is what
allowed us to do
newtonian physics kepler
everything i mean we understood so much
but let's ask let's think about this
question
can it be measured whether the earth is
a center of universe or not no
right there's no way to measure it we
have no
no way of thinking what is the center of
the universe
it's not
something which is uh directly
measurable
and i think this is interesting because
it shows that science is not just about
measurable things
science as i said before is about
organizing your thinking in some way
so if you organize your thinking as the
earth and
not moving everything going around it in
some way
you're just messing up your your
understanding you just it's too
complicated you're not getting out of it
but if you start to organize things
first this is
the sun and then say oh no actually it's
not the sun the sun is also moving and
then you're better again
um
there's no center in the universe
there's no preferred reference frame um
some of property some of the other
properties
you
reorganize your thinking in a better and
better ways and of course the previous
one looked a little bit naive always
okay it's not true that the sun is the
center of india is going around it's
more complicated story like the one you
said it's more correct
um
so
science is not about
true or false
is not just about true or false clear
statement
it's about the best way we found so far
for thinking about the universe
the one that allows us to understand
things to predict things to write laws
more easily
i think me and you think
quite alike and i heard a hint of it
when you said that there are different
quantum mechanical interpretations and
in some sense they're each right
now that phrase they're each right
that's
i'm not driven by promoting peace even
though it seems like i'm ironic it's
just that
look i i didn't say they're each right i
see i said they're each
coherent and possible
they are not wrong
let me explain so before copernicus
earth center copernicus no sun is
centered einstein hey you're both right
in some way now i'm curious as i
investigate more philosophy even
religion
just like there was this line in your
book about up and down and it seems to
make no sense it seems contradictory
until you view it from another point of
view and you see oh well what's up to
australians is down to us canadians and
so on
okay well i'm also i also see or also
wonder how much of religion and well
philosophy in general but let's just
take religion
it's it seems like
the major religions contradict with one
another but are they true contradictions
when viewed from another perspective is
there another one in which you can say
actually that's right in some way that's
right in some other way that's right now
okay i've just outlined in a sense my
outlook my personality
do you view problems like that or
do you see what i said as having any
truth or is there something that i
should be aware of as a limitation in
that thinking
well it's it's uh
you bring different things together um
first of all uh
let me separate my answer into parts
first of all
religion is a very complicated phenomena
very very very wide phenomenon
uh
you mentioned the big religion
religions the big religions first of all
they're different from one another
they're different properties second they
are institutions their people their
history
their center of powers sometimes the
systems of beliefs they make statement
their moral systems
there are ways for people for thinking
the world their way of people to getting
together you know you go to the church
and you find friends
so um
it's
it makes no sense to say
uh it's certain religion right or wrong
and it's like saying is the united
states right or wrong well it's in my
opinion is wrong in some things right
and some other thing
i disagree with some of its politics i
like some of its uh obvious ideology or
whatever so um
so uh
if you isolate within religion
a certain
moral
aspect
definitely you you
i am not religious at all i'm an atheist
i feel perfectly sympathetic i mean i'm
happy to
fight together with some religious
people for the peace in the world i
don't know
um if you isolate some other aspects uh
like the belief that was a creator which
is a person i just find it wrong
i i think it's wrong
so
uh it's a very complicated story and i i
i see a lot of bad in religions i also
see a lot of good religions i i don't
want to enter in which one i think is
strong
um
now let me let me zoom into your your
point uh because you said well does this
mean that tamal
there is always some something right
i want to say always save it yeah okay i
would say the the other way around
there's always something wrong
it's more interesting namely
uh i think that we
we humans live in a dialogue
and the good of the dialogue
is that we change our mind because of
what we hear from the other guy right
that's how culture has developed that's
how science has developed
and each time so
we're always
the best thinking
it's always in search of what is wrong
not what is right okay what is wrong
with my thinking what is wrong in your
thinking because that's what allows us
to go ahead right
is
the
the great uh step of copernicus
has not been you know to to to
to
to have the idea that the earth goes
around has been to recognize that being
attached to the idea that the entire
center is wrong
just found something wrong in the
uh
in the basis
of uh
um
of the way astronomers thought for for
centuries and you know a couple
generations later kepler
did the same game he discovered that for
two millennia people try to make sense
of what we see in the sky in terms of
circles and he says this is not circles
they're ellipses okay so after two
millennia of circles they said well
forget circles
so what is interesting what we are wrong
okay
and i think there are a lot of wrong
ideas in instead of all
inside a lot of beautiful
moral social
human constructions and behaviors there
are just wrong ideas in many religions
um
it has to be so because they are so
contradictory of one another of course
there's some wrong ideas i mean they
cannot be all right so the fact that we
can learn from one another and
we can often um
take a larger point of view um
does not change the fact that there's a
precise sense in which
the pre-copernicus system the ptolemic
system is just wrong factually wrong and
copernicus system is wrong
and kepler
is wrong because
planets don't go along ellipses they
move more complicated and newton's
theory is wrong because if you take
newton's theory
and you
use neutral theory to compute the motion
of mercury you just get it wrong
okay you miss a little correction which
comes correct with generativity
so
um
in a sense uh
i'm
i'm not
i think there is to learn from from
different things i think it's good to
give
keep an open mind and to listen
different perspective
but the interesting of the dialogue is
precisely when we can
step out from mistakes in one one one
situation or the other